I would never set myself up as somehow the
oracle of truth or value-free judgment.
You know, I’m really not that different
from the next guy. . . . I am a contrarian.
I think I can admit to that.
Looking at the MacDonald case, I was bothered
by it. I don’t know how else to describe
it. There’s a line in a Robert Mitchum
film noir where Mitchum says, “I could see
the frame, but I couldn’t see the picture.”
It’s one of the great film noir lines. . . . It’s
not so much that I could see the frame but
I couldn’t see the picture – this was
certainly true inThe Thin Blue Line25
years ago. Here, there was something deeply
unconvincing about the case that had been
made, particularly the case that had been
made by Joe McGinniss inFatal Vision...
too pat, too slick, too simple, too easy.
What’s so interesting about this story When
you have a theory – say you’re an investigator,
which would be the best and easiest way of
talking about this – you have a theory about
what happened, a theory about who did it or
how they did it. The term confirmation bias
– I hesitate to use it, but . . . you have
a theory. The question is, does that theory
in some way determine the kind of evidence
that you look for and the kind of evidence
that you reject? If you truly believe there
were no intruders in the house and that Jeffrey
MacDonald was the person who killed his family,
you may not look for evidence that suggests
that there were intruders in the house.
You might not even notice it. It might become
for all intents and purposes invisible to
you.
I wrote a book prior to this book,Believing
Is Seeing, which is – I almost think the
title should have beenDisbelieving Is Seeingbecause
it shows you this interplay between how we
see things and the beliefs that we hold about
the world. Vision, which we often like to
think of as neutral or value-free, is anything
but that. We see on the basis of what we
believe, not the other way around. And that
idea is very much part of aWilderness of
Erroras well.
Cops come on a scene, look around, see the
position of furniture.
And often you quickly – I think this is
a human problem – you come to one narrative
or another, an explanation of what I’m looking
at. What is this? How do I explain this?
What happened here? Who’s responsible?
Who’s the real perpetrator? And so on
and so forth. In the case of MacDonald,
the police very quickly decided it was him,
not just that it was him but that he had staged
the crime scene, he had arranged the crime
scene to make it look like there had been
intruders. But he had done it in such a
ham-handed pathetic way that it was easily
unmasked as a fraud. . . . You idiot! Look
at this! . . . This is a pathetic attempt
to deceive us into thinking that there were
intruders when we know better. We know there
were none.
So there you go. You have an idea, a theory,
and as a result of that theory how did it
affect the next 40 years? Yes, it affected
the next 40 years in many very powerful and
sad ways.